buen día pues un plan bastante ambicioso
dos horas duró el discurso de manuel
marco en el elíseo para enumerar diez
objetivos de este plan que busca dar
mayor competitividad a todas las
industrias del país todo esto con un
presupuesto de 30 mil millones de euros
sus ideas principales en realidad él
dijo una es la de producir más otra la
de vivir mejor y también de ser mucho
más independientes para decirles digamos
de los puntos más importantes de todo lo
dicho durante esas dos horas una parte
tiene que ver con la energía de manuel
marco se apoya bastante en la energía
nuclear y espera que para 2030 haya en
francia- mini reactores nucleares que de
hecho gestionan mucho mejor los
desechos también espera que el país se
convierta en el líder mundial en la
producción de hidrógeno verde esto que
se conoce como la energía del futuro y
espera de de hecho pues que en los
próximos 78 años en el país haya éxito 2
gb fábricas de electrolizadores que son
los que fabrican este tipo de energía
así que de hecho esta energía pues sea
también utilizada en otras industrias
habló igualmente de la transporte por
una parte de la industria
automóvil allí espera el que en francia
se puedan fabricar unos dos millones de
automóviles eléctricos y que de hecho
esto permita que salgan del parque
automotor pues todos estos vehículos
contaminantes también hace una apuesta
por la industria aerospacial de con
horizonte de 2026 la utilización de
impulsadores que pueden ser
reutilizables también el lanzamiento de
mini satélites una apuesta por que
francia sea el primer país en en
fabricar un avión bajo en carbono de
bajas emisiones así que bastante es
bastante ambicioso este el proyecto y
bueno da una idea también de lo que él
quiere para el país en caso de ser
reelegido el próximo mes de abril